[Music]
you are the Explorer give me a hard copy
Fred your dream to be enforced I wish to
find the lost what we seek far greater
than you ever imagined
your soul will never be quiet until you
find this place
it is your sting
there's a major exploration afoot
terrible disease murder of savages the
journey may well mean your life don't go
you'll not know you when you return I
know this is a sacrifice for all of us
they will be worth a man's reach should
exceed his craft I am proposing in
Amazonia contain a hidden civilization
if we may find a city where one was
considered impossible to exist it's many
well write a whole new chapter in human
are you insisting that these savages
there are equal their civilization may
well three days off I call it death the
ultimate piece of the human puzzle
strongly advise you to abort the mission
become far too dangerous must come back
the rest of tiny
I stay here and struck them to provide
for the children while you wondered the
jungle he does care ashes you don't even
care about them don't care a shallow
let's search for said I can no longer
bear the cost
you've come to doubt its existence now
not only does it said provide all the
answers you seek from
you
you